-Republicans and right-wing
pundits are focusing
on the leak of
the Supreme Court's draft ruling
overturning Roe v. Wade,
rather than the ruling itself.
Meanwhile, more evidence
is emerging that potentially
links Donald Trump
to the militia groups
involved in the attempted coup
on January 6th.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
The right has been trying
to overturn Roe for 50 years,
and in order
to achieve that goal,
they've broken every
conceivable norm in their path
and nearly detonated
our democracy.
In fact, they partnered
with a monstrous demagogue
who literally tried
to overthrow our democracy.
And as part of
that Faustian bargain,
Trump promised to give them
the judges they wanted
as long as
they looked the other way
during his many crimes
and abuses, and for years,
Trump has gone out of his way
to remind Republicans
of the judges he gave them in
order to retain their loyalty.
-I've always heard
how important judges are.
Now we know
how important they are.
I have 252 beautiful,
brand-new, conservative,
wonderful judges.
We have confirmed 191
brand-new, beautiful
federal judges.
All those judges,
those beautiful judges.
-No matter what
he's talking about,
he makes it sound
like real estate.
[As Trump] We have so many
brand-new, beautiful,
split-level judges,
all new appliances,
ready now for an easy move.
These judges won't last.
Book a viewing today.
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice] Trump got
the GOP over the finish line,
but this plot
did not begin with him,
and it's not unique
to his presidency.
Overturning Roe has been
a nearly singular,
obsessive goal of the extremist
right for half a century,
as Senator Elizabeth Warren
noted after a protest
outside the Supreme Court
on Tuesday.
-The Republicans have been
working toward this day
for decades.
They have been
out there plotting,
carefully cultivating these
Supreme Court justices
so they could have a majority
on the bench
who would accomplish something
that the majority of Americans
do not want.
-It's true,
they've spent decades
carefully cultivating
these justices.
They look like they were
grown in a lab
to overturn abortion rights.
I mean, look at this guy.
He looks like the dean
who threatens
to shut down the fraternity
in every '80s teen comedy.
If he had written
the draft opinion,
it would have ended with,
"We rule that Roe
must be overturned
and also that a werewolf
can't play basketball!"
[ Laughter ]
Of course, it won't surprise you
to learn that
instead of responding
to the substance
that Warren and the protesters
are saying, the depraved weirdos
who make up today's
Republican Party
decided instead to mock
the people who attended.
For example, there's Florida
Congressman Matt Gaetz,
who is currently under
federal investigation
over unpaid parking tickets --
Wait. Sorry, I read that wrong.
Over whether he had
a sexual relationship
with a 17-year-old and paid
for her to travel with him
in violation of federal
sex trafficking laws.
And I'm sure he also hasn't paid
all his parking tickets.
Gaetz chose a line of attack
that quickly backfired.
-One lawmaker appearing to stoke
the flames of controversy,
Florida Congressman
Matt Gaetz tweeting,
"How many of the women
rallying against overturning Roe
are over-educated,
under-loved millennials
who sadly return from protests
to a lonely microwave dinner
with their cats,
and no Bumble matches?"
-It is very telling that you
think "overeducated" is a burn.
"So, what grade are you in?"
"Oh, I'm a sophomore
in college."
"Sophomore? Sorry, you're
a little overeducated for me.
Once you've read
'Fahrenheit 451,'
you're basically a grandma
to ol' Gaetzy!"
[ Laughter ]
When they're not
mocking protesters,
they are, of course,
pretending to be indignant
over the leak itself,
rather than celebrating
the outcome,
because they know
overturning Roe
and criminalizing abortion
are deeply unpopular
with a huge majority
of voters.
So, instead, they want
to throw the leaker in jail.
-What happened to the court
today was the saddest chapter
in the history of
the United States Supreme Court.
This was despicable,
it's dangerous, and it was dumb.
-If that left-wing
law clerk succeeds,
it will be the most
grotesque politicization
of the Supreme Court
in the history of our nation.
You mentioned
an FBI investigation.
I hope there is a serious one.
And I hope whoever
is responsible for this
not only is fired instantly,
but is prosecuted
and serves real jail time
for violating the confidences
of the Supreme Court.
-There is no duo in history
worse than Ted Cruz
and Lindsey Graham.
You know who was
a much better duo?
Milli Vanilli.
Or as they're known
in Supreme Court parlance,
Milli v. Anilli.
Next time...
Next time Cruz flees his state
during a weather emergency.
I'm betting he'll...
-♪ Blame it on the rain ♪
[ Laughter ]
By the way, if you got
that musical reference,
Matt Gaetz doesn't want
to date you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Anyway...
If you want to talk
about politicizing the court,
why don't we talk about the fact
that a sitting justice,
Clarence Thomas,
was the sole vote
in a case that would have
allowed Trump to keep documents
relevant to the January 6th
insurrection private --
documents, it turns out,
that could have involved
Thomas' wife, Ginni Thomas,
who repeatedly
sent text messages
to Trump's chief of staff
pushing him to overturn
the 2020 election.
Thomas didn't recuse himself
from that case.
His wife was texting Meadows
insane theories
about election fraud and ideas
for how to keep Trump in power.
And really,
I cannot stress enough
how unhinged these texts were.
-The Washington Post obtained
copies of messages
that had been turned over
to the January 6 committee,
revealing that Ginni Thomas
sent former Trump
Chief of Staff Mark Meadows
a barrage of texts in the weeks
after the 2020 election,
urging him to try
to overturn the results.
She referred to wild,
far-right conspiracy theories,
sending Meadows a link
to an absolutely
just insane YouTube video
that's since been taken down,
which was centered around
a fake QAnon conspiracy theory.
After she texted
that video to Meadows,
"Thomas added, quote,
I hope this is true."
-Right after the election,
she quoted to Meadows
the language then circulating
on pro-Trump sites.
Quote, "Biden crime family and
ballot fraud co-conspirators
(elected officials, bureaucrats,
social media censorship mongers,
fake stream media
reporters, etc)
are being arrested and detained
for ballot fraud right now
and over coming days, and will
be living in barges off Gitmo
to face military tribunals
for sedition,"
adding, "I hope this is true."
-Now, Ginni.
Personally, when a text ends
with "I hope this is true,"
I prefer that it follows
something like,
"Heard you're coming home
for the holidays,"
or, "A little bird told me
you got that promotion."
Not "Biden crime family will be
living in barges off Gitmo,"
you cuckoo nut-bird!
Do you travel
with a life preserver?
Because, lady, you are
off the [bleep] deep end.
And you may say, "Eh, she's not
a Supreme Court justice.
She's his wife.
Leave her alone."
First of all, it's a massive
conflict of interest.
Second, she was
encouraging a coup.
Third, why does
she get to text Mark Meadows?
My wife doesn't get
to text my guests
before they come on my show.
Because if she did,
I knew what she would text them.
[ Laughter ]
This stuff is really deranged.
She thought there were
secret watermarks on ballots
and that the Biden crime family
was being detained at Gitmo
for election fraud.
On barges, no less.
If you ask me, she's doing
disservice to the name Ginni.
Ginni should be the cool aunt
who lets you have champagne
at New Year's when you're 15,
and drives a Jeep Wrangler
with a bunch
of Phish stickers on it
and has a cool roommate
named Debbie
who has three
rescue dogs and --
Oh, I just think I...
I think I just realized
something about Aunt Ginni.
[ Laughter ]
Alright.
Good for Aunt Ginni.
Certainly...
She's certainly doing better
than Aunt Barb.
Aunt Barb!
Still looking for Mr. Right.
In reality, of course,
it turned out the criminals
were the ones
trying to overthrow
a free and fair election
through violent means,
like the militia group
the Oath Keepers.
Just today we found out that
the head of that group allegedly
had a contact close to Trump
and tried to reach out to Trump
through an intermediary
during the coup.
-New court papers have revealed
just how far a north Texas man
was reportedly willing to go
to overturn
the 2020 presidential election.
Stuart Rhodes, the leader of the
Oath Keepers militia movement,
allegedly called
an intermediary
after the Capitol attack
on January 6th
and asked to be put in contact
with former President Trump
so that the president could
authorize their militia
to forcibly oppose
the transfer of power.
-This individual denied Rhodes'
request to speak directly
with President Trump.
-He never got through to Trump,
but I'm guessing it's because
Trump thought the Oath Keepers
was the name of a charity
he promised to donate to
in the '80s.
"Hi. We're calling
from the Oath Keepers Fund.
We're trying to track down
a pledge for $1 million
Mr. Trump made in 1984."
[As Trump]
That's so weird.
I could've sworn
I put the check in the mail.
Maybe it got lost --
-♪ Blame it on the rain ♪
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice] You know, playing
a Milli Vanilli track early
is how they caught
Milli Vanilli.
[ Laughter ]
You know what, I think
it's still gonna play.
That's w--
[ Laughing ]
You guys, take it
out of your head.
Get it out of your head.
Let it surprise you.
[As Trump] That's weird,
I could've sworn
I put the check
in the mail.
Maybe it got lost
during a hurricane.
I guess I'll have to...
-♪ Blame it on the rain ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-'Cause the rain...
Let me tell you something
about the rain.
If I've learned...
The rain don't mind.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
[Normal voice]
But let's get back to Roe.
An extremist movement
of far-right conservatives
who spent five decades
carefully orchestrating
the outcome we're seeing now.
Their devil's bargain with Trump
got them across the finish line,
but the assault
on abortion rights
isn't unique to him,
and it didn't start with him.
For example,
after the 1992 decision
Planned Parenthood v. Casey
reaffirmed Roe,
anti-abortion activists
shifted to a new strategy.
They launched a barrage
of new abortion restrictions
to see which ones
the court would uphold.
-The joint opinion delivered
by Justices O'Connor,
Souter, and Kennedy
crafted a middle position.
They upheld Roe,
but changed the standard
by which abortion laws
would be judged.
They established instead
the undue burden standard.
A law would be invalid,
they declared,
if it placed
substantial obstacles
in the path of a woman
seeking an abortion.
-People got the impression
that abortion was safe,
Roe v. Wade was safe.
All the pro-choice people
went home.
But what happened is pro-lifers
started to pass legislation
to test what exactly
is an undue burden.
Let's pass this bill.
Is that undue?
Let's pass that bill.
And let's see where
the courts draw the line.
-Anti-abortion activists
basically adopted
the same strategy
for attacking Roe
that your 5-year-old takes
when you tell them
not to run too close
to the pool.
"Is this too close?" "Yes."
"What about this?" "Yes."
"What about this?"
"Zachary Hudson Hamilton III,
if you do not move away
from the pool right now,
so help me God,
I will end you."
Sorry, guys. I shouldn't have
that third nitro cold brew.
So, they've been working
towards this for decades.
Kavanaugh, for example,
once hailed
Justice William Rehnquist
as his judicial hero,
in part for his dissent
in Roe v. Wade.
But when it came time
to testify to the Senate
about their positions
on Roe,
Kavanaugh and his fellow
Trump appointee Neil Gorsuch
played the usual
rhetorical games and lied,
even though everyone knew
or should have known at the time
they were brazenly lying.
-Senator, I said
that it's settled
as a precedent
of the Supreme Court
entitled the respect under
principles of stare decisis.
And one of the important things
to keep in mind
about Roe v. Wade
is that it has been reaffirmed
many times
over the past 45 years.
-Had you ever met
President Trump personally?
-[ Clears throat ]
Not until my interview.
-In that interview, did he ever
ask you to overrule Roe v. Wade?
-No, Senator.
-What would you have done if --
if he had asked?
-Senator, I would have
walked out the door.
-"I would have walked
out the door.
And then I would have stopped
and turned around
and winked so hard
my cufflinks flew off."
[ Laughter ]
Everyone knew these guys
were lying
because Trump had
explicitly promised,
in a desperate bid to grovel
for the support
of the religious right,
to appoint pro-life justices
who would overturn Roe.
And that's why Republicans
stuck with him
through his crimes
and abuses of power,
so they could reap
their end of the bargain.
Republicans looked the other way
during the Trump years
and spent their time
scrolling through Bumble
looking for...
-Beautiful judges.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver cooks
and brings over 2 million meals
a year to men,
women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses.
And they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.